what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest
my sister amelia she is 14 years old
say hi hi um and what she did was she
came in my room and said
[Music]
you're the hannah sister ever all i said
was i'm bored
and i said do you want to react to a
video with me since
i'm the best sister ever she said yeah
anything for you i'll do anything to
support you
what actually happened was okay let's
let's stop now before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification hey i brought
you a cupcake
don't tell them you're frosting all over
your
i'm frosting on my face i'm supposed to
be on a diet
um okay don't forget to subscribe to the
channel
bring that notification bell um but
today we're gonna be reacting
to kevin samuels talking to a 22 year
old woman on ig
live she's really excited to be here and
yeah we're gonna start um i wanted to
know
what needs to be done
to i guess attract a high value man
percy do you know what a high value man
is
i don't really care but no okay but for
the video
so these girls want to attract a guy um
that's high value and it basically means
he has to make a certain amount of money
um there's other things too like he has
to be useful to like a group
he has to be um
he has to have made that money for three
years he has to be over a certain age
but like
it's like basically money and like a
couple other things
that make sense yeah thank you what you
got
um i wanted to know what
needs to be done to i guess attract a
high value man percy
why um
because i feel like that's where i want
my life to be
in the future futuristic terms but i'm
willing
to do what it takes to get one okay are
you in college
um i went to medical school
did you graduate from college yeah i
went to nyu
i did a um certificate program and i'm a
surgical technologist
did you get a ba or bs um
no it's like okay all right so you
didn't graduate from college
no but i got a certificate in the
program that i did
okay so when you say you're going to
medical school i'm going back
for um for nursing all right
so um why do you need a high va
why do you need a high value man um
because like i feel like i've dated like
the regular
the average guys and i feel like they
don't treat me the way
i need to be treated um
a lot of the guys that i've like dated
in the past they were
[Music]
um i would say like thuggish
kind of in a way young lady how about
you man it's not a get out of jail
free card and it's not a meal ticket a
high value man is a job
a hard job the hardest job you'll ever
have in your life
is to be the wife of a high value man
it's not a life of luxury it's not a who
buy me a bmw
and i just get up in the morning or you
go off to work and i just sit in the
house all day and watch tv that ain't it
you're upset you're up at five o'clock
in the morning going to the gym
working out making sure that by the time
you get back home and the kids are up
you got the kids breakfast ready kids
right now
out of the door your husband's stuff
ready to make sure when he goes up so he
has to do
to make sure that when everybody else
leaves that you get the house straight
get the meals prep get everything done
to make sure when the kids get back home
the homework gets done
to make sure when i come through the
door that the meal is ready the kids are
ready to go
and all the money and [ __ ] that we're
working to earn you are doing all this
other stuff you get and by this by the
way
you gotta stay in shape and also the
stuff to make sure that i ain't doing
nothing for the kids you gotta get the
kids all ready to go
parent-teacher conferences homework
everything else i just look over
from a from an executive position and
say great then you get the kids ready
going stuff and so forth blah and then
you serve your husband wash rinse and
repeat the rest of your life
it's not a life of luxury do you believe
that um
an independent like not an independent
woman but a woman that has stuff herself
could keep a high value man a man
because i feel like sometimes
no what do you think so far
i feel like he's saying all women should
be housewives
no he's saying that okay so he's saying
that it's a very small percentage of men
so he's saying like the top men that can
have any girl they want they usually
want housewives because they don't need
the other girl's money
so he's saying like if you want to be
married to those guys this is what they
want they don't need your money
okay which is interesting because um
like mom and dad obviously mom works and
dad like makes a lot of money right
so he'd be like in that category but i
asked dad
like what he thought because i was like
dad like you're in that income category
would you prefer
mom stayed home you know what he said
what he said yeah which is kind of funny
because i didn't think he would say yes
but he did i would have assumed he would
have really
it's dad what do you mean he wants to do
everything himself
but he never has plans and then it ends
up falling through
yeah true okay
you young ladies think this is a like a
fantasy
not per se but i know like when i like i
know i'm still young and stuff and i
have like a lot of stuff ahead of me but
like even dating guys when i tell them
you know
um that i'm a surgical technician for
right now and i still want to like
do more stuff and go back to school he
um he's in the medical field he's a
surgical attack too
so i kind of like that mother and your
father yeah i was raised with both of
them
is your father helping you vet and sort
through me
um no no
you don't involve your father in your
room do you think that dad should help
you pick a husband
no why because he
probably wouldn't care he would know
dad cares a lot
he he cares more than you'd think
yeah you don't think he would care who
his daughter spends the rest of
your life with i feel like mom would
care more
i think mom would be more vocal about it
because dad kind of is like do what you
what makes you happy but he would
definitely care who you pick as a
husband
but so would you
if you brought someone like home would
you ask mom and dad if they like them
probably yeah just out of curiosity and
if they said no would you consider
breaking up with them
depends yeah i would actually
because i think that i'm gonna have to
deal with my parents forever
and it's gonna be hard for the rest of
their life hannah
yeah i know but i'm saying like it's
hard
okay i was just curious for your
thoughts romantic life
i tried to but he's so like um
like i don't he's more high demanding
than me
like exactly because he knows what's out
here you need to listen to him
instead of guys you don't know or
instagram
oh
okay do you not think he loves you
i mean we have a complicated you think
he loves you that's not what i ask you i
don't care if you like him i said do you
think he loves you
yeah did he did he put a roof over here
yes ooh in your stomach yes make sure
you guys out of high school right
yep you got any babies nope good you
sound like you did his damn job
respecting him
start worrying about a high value man go
get a regular guy like your dad sounds
like that's what you need soccer did his
job
come on
okay what any other thoughts you have
not really what do you think of kevin
samuels so far
i feel like sometimes he has a point but
other times he's just
being rude what do you think he doesn't
have a point about
well it depends on what you're talking
about in this video was there anything
you feel like he didn't have a point on
i've already forgotten what 90 percent
of what he said hannah you're asking the
wrong person here okay that's all right
um okay guys we're gonna actually react
to a couple videos tonight
so stay stay tuned don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell and i will
talk to you guys next time
stop shaking your head